[Music]
straight ahead
all on crime daily we don't know where
an accused murderer's at
prosecutors seek a new arrest warrant
for the accused kenosha shooter
kyle reinhaus but a judge denies their
emotion new footage of the capital right
gives an inside look into the deadly
insurrection what it means for the
impeachment trial of the former
president
they have first played in the crowd they
are spreading the crowd
plus hustler magazine editor and first
amendment champion larry flint dies
a look back at the landmark supreme
court decision and the controversy
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a judge in wisconsin is denying a
request by the state
to rearrest the accused kenosha shooter
prosecutors requested a new warrant for
kyle renthouse after learning he moved
and didn't tell the court of his new
address
reinhaus is charged with killing two
people and wounding a third during
protests last summer
the defense says reinhaus moved from
illinois to a safe house
after receiving death threats the father
of one of the deceased and the surviving
victim
asked the judge to raise ringhouse's
bond
whatever the statutes are they must be
wrong because this guy can just go and
do whatever he wants
after he killed our son our son didn't
get to spend thanksgiving with us
but rittenhouse did he got to spend all
kinds of time at the bar
live it up making videos with his white
supremacist friends
singing videos with a shirt that says
free is f
you're not going to be free as f
justice is going to be served to you
i would like to restate that it is in my
opinion
that mr rittenhouse has shown a pattern
of lack of remorse during this
during this bond time before before
trial and
i would also recommend that they'll be
raised to 4 million
the defense provided the court with a
p.o box and the judge ultimately ruled
in their favor
so he is in violation for not updating
his address
and that has to be addressed going
forward
but he also as mr richards has pointed
out
he appeared on the last hearing which
was the one
which was the return notice he was there
at mr richard's office so i'm assuming
he came from wherever he was
to uh to uh racine to attend that
meeting and uh he's here today
so i'm going to deny the motions and
quite apart from the interests of the
defendant
after what this town has been through
in the in the last six months i don't
want any more problems
the police don't need any more problems
we don't need to have people's safety in
jeopardy in any way
so i think that the desire
that the bond or that the defendant's
address be kept
[Music]
from public scrutiny uh is a legitimate
one
this is highly irregular we have a right
to know this
i would argue the public has a right to
know it as well i understand the court's
ruling from stealing it from the public
but our office has a responsibility to
enforce the laws
enforce the bond here to file bond
bail jumping charges if there's a
violation of that and we cannot do our
job without this information
the sheriff's department was in charge
of reporting
bond violations and the like to uh to to
us and i think the same situation is
true now
hearing is over thank you the defendant
doesn't reside in kenosha county your
honor the sheriff can't help
thank you joining us here today is
criminal defense attorney imran ansari
and terry austin
imran i get it's a violation of his bond
but
i mean we're both defense attorneys
we've seen this it's a minor
infraction do you think the judge at the
end of the day made the right call
so brian the main concern here for the
court for the judge
is if the written house is a flight risk
and the judge was very uh you know
particular to point out
that rittenhouse has appeared at each of
his appearances
so this is um in the grand scheme of
things
a minor uh sort of flub he was supposed
to update the address
which is usually the case for a
defendant who is out on bail
um he didn't do that and i think his
attorney did make a compelling argument
that
uh you know there may be some safety
risks here and the judge also pointed
out that
written house although he's supposed to
provide an
address uh you know where he is uh
residing he's not
actually as per the terms of this bond
um
ordered to be there meaning in house
arrest so yes um listen
is it gonna compel his appearance i
think that was what the judge
is looking for he there has not been any
issue with him appearing previously
and the judge was confident that he
would appear again absolutely terry the
judge also denied the request to
increase the bond
to two hundred thousand dollars thoughts
you know what i agree with the judge's
ruling for all the reasons that imran
just stated
this was really a technicality yes he
should have
updated his address but we know he's not
going to try to flee because
he showed up at this hearing so why
would you increase the amount of the
bond so
while it wasn't a correct address listed
i think it was just a failure to
communicate
and the bond should remain as it is
absolutely and ultimately the question
is is going to come back to court and i
think the judge
is following the law in that regard
thank you both now
to the latest on the so-called doomsday
call duel terry has an update on the
on one of the motions we've been
following closely
brian i've just learned that the judge
has denied the defense's request
to reconsider disqualifying the
prosecutor overseeing
their case lori valo and her husband
chad dabell
are facing charges of conspiring to
conceal and destroy
evidence in the deaths of valo's two
children the bodies of j.j
and tyler ryan were discovered buried in
a shallow grave on day bells idaho
property
they're not charged with murder but the
prosecutor was heard doing a secretly
recording meeting
with valo's sister saying he plans to
file conspiracy to commit
murder charges the defense now wants
prosecutor rob wood
removed but the judge and now the idaho
supreme court
upholds that there is no basis for his
removal
still ahead on law and crime daily trump
impeachment trial enters its third day
our expert analysis on the legal
arguments but first
never before seen footage of the capitol
riot the bravery of the officers and how
close congress actually came to danger
next
[Music]
in patient managers used a collection of
never before seen or
heard radio traffic security footage and
body cam video from the capitol building
to lay out their case for why they
believe former president donald trump
incited insurrection on january 6th
watch the red dot which moves up the
lower steps of the capitol
indicating the approximate location of
the rioters
as they surge past the police the second
man through the window
is wearing full tactical body armor
and is carrying a baseball bat others
are carrying riot shields
and they said that anyone they got their
hands on
they would have killed including nancy
pelosi
and that quote they would have killed
vice president
mike pence if given the chance
officer goodman passes senator mitt
romney
and directs him to turn around in order
to get to safety
and watch how officer goodman provokes
the riders and
purposefully draws them away from the
door to the senate chamber
and towards the other officers waiting
down the hall
the mob continued to look for speaker
pelosi
throughout the time they occupied the
capitol including
invading her offices the staff moves
from their offices
through the halls and then enters a door
on the right-hand side
that's the outer door of a conference
room
which also has an inner door that they
barricaded with furniture
one of the riders you can see is
throwing his
body against the door three times until
he breaks
open that outer door luckily when faced
with the inner door
he moves on this security video
shows ashley babbitt followed by others
in the mob
turning the corner toward the house
lobby doors where the members were
leaving
minutes later at 2 44 pm ashley babbitt
attempted to climb through a shattered
window
into the house lobby to protect the
members
in the lobby an officer discharged his
weapon
many members are still wearing their gas
masks they walk just
feet away from where capitol police are
holding an insurrectionist at gunpoint
this security video from 2 56 pm shows
the mob in the house of representatives
wing
on the second floor of the capitol
insurrectionists who are still inside
the building
are fighting with the police who were
overwhelmed in trying to get them out
the senate chamber was not evacuated
until 2 30 p.m
the mob had been in the building for
more than 15 minutes
you cannot see it in this footage but
quick thinking
senate floor staff grabbed
and protected the electoral ballots
that the mob was after additional
security footage shows how leader
schumer
and the members of his protective detail
had a near miss
with the mob they came within just yards
of riders
and had to turn around seconds later
they return
and run back down the hallway and
officers immediately shut the door
and use their bodies to keep them safe
for hours and hours these
insurrectionists
were in hand-to-hand combat with these
brave men and women
the town
[Music]
140 officers injured three
officers who ultimately lost their lives
we all know that awful day
could have been so much worse the only
reason it was not
was because of the extraordinary bravery
of the men
and women of the capitol police and the
metropolitan police departments
it's a lot closer than we thought
initially back to describe the
impeachment trial of former president
trump as defense attorney imran ansari
and co-host terry austin
terry the defense at the end of the day
is trying to in the united state defense
that of
former president trump to show that
there is no direct link between the
former president
and the insurrection do you think the
house impeachment managers though
are addressing that issue in their
arguments they absolutely are brian they
did an
excellent job it was succinct it was
clear and it was dramatic
what they said is that there was a
provocation and that that provocation
started when trump
established the lie that it was a
fraudulent election
then they said there was an attack on
january 6 and on january 6
he told his supporters to go down to the
capitol
and you know start a riot and that is
exactly what they did he said fight back
and then they showed that there was harm
and i thought that this was particularly
insightful they said that not only was
there harm to life
but liberty meaning that now the capital
is
all gated up and also property so they
did an excellent job showing the
connection
between what he said and what they did
now imran that's the connection the
house impeachment managers are laying
out as we saw
there a case of the former president
incited a riot through social media
posts
and videos on january 6 to you as
someone who has represented
a lot of people a lot of famous people
in great cases
are these arguments persuasive so brian
i actually think that they're doing
a very persuasive job in presenting
their case
it's very prosecutorial it's very
evidence driven
they're relying heavily on on the videos
that
were taken on that day and the way
they're doing it
is that they're laying out block by
block piece by piece
and looking to connect it to the
statements to the actions of the
president
will it carry the day well just based on
the senate makeup
perhaps not will it carry the day in
terms of just what evidence has been put
forth
the videos and connections to the
president
i think they're doing a very effective
job if at anything in a symbolic sense
absolutely we'll keep an eye on that as
it's just day three of many days in this
impeachment trial
coming up on law on crime daily an
arrest made in the death of a teen found
in a sugar cane field
plus a shocking new report of a plea
deal ex-cop derek shovin
was willing to agree to why it was
rejected still ahead
a louisiana woman is facing criminal
charges in the death of a 15-year-old
boy
after his body was found in a sugar cane
field
authorities say que juan bobby charles's
body was discovered in shallow water
on november 3rd 2020. his mother
reported him as missing four days
earlier to the local police
police say the boy had been picked up
outside his home by a woman and her 17
year old son
the iberia parish sheriff's office says
37 year old janet irving
is facing charges of contributing to the
delinquency of a minor
and failure to report a missing child
janet irvin was arraigned in the 16th
judicial court
the judge has set her bond at 400 000
i want the public to understand that
anyone who has been incarcerated has
a bond set and if they can meet that
bond
they have the right to bond out at this
time
janet irvin has not met that bond
i want to ensure the residents of iberia
parish that your sheriff's office has
collected the appropriate evidence
needed by law enforcement personnel to
legally
obtain an arrest warrant for janet irvin
not relying on any private investigators
findings
all right back to break down this tragic
death and disappearance is defense
attorney imran ansari and terry austin
terry krawon's mother chose to show his
disfigured face
publicly something reminiscent of emmett
till
for the world to see and she did this
so she can kind of push why this was so
bad but do you see
any potential civil charges coming up
out of this story and against who
well you know it does remind me of
emmett till they both involved
a young black child who was gruesomely
killed and
we know emmett till was racially
motivated we're not so sure here but it
could have been
you know as far as the civil case i
think there are reasons to bring a
wrongful death action
she's claiming the mother is that she
reported him missing one day and yet
nothing was done for days after the fact
and the sheriff is disputing exactly the
date he was reported missing
and also whether an amber alert should
have been made here so she has grounds i
think
for bringing a wrongful death and maybe
even a civil rights claim
now imran all of that's really
interesting because as i understand it
the local police never notified state
police
and it's the state police who actually
have the power to issue an amber alert
the police also didn't report his
disappearance to local media
the family is placing the blame of
kwaiwan's death squarely at the police's
feet
what do you think yeah brian that's um
in my opinion a little problematic for
the police i think there could have been
a break-in procedure there may be a
procedure when someone is
missing particularly a child on the
local level
that wasn't followed and we know that
the state police did not get that amber
alert out there
because they were not notified it also
may lead to some changes in some
legislation
locally down there perhaps they're going
to give the local police the authority
to issue an amber alert but i think it's
pretty pretty uh interesting
um regarding that interplay and that may
be the grounds for a civil suit
absolutely thank you both when we come
back remembering larry flint
the media mogul the scandal the lawsuits
and the legacy
a judge presiding over the george floyd
case has denied the state's request to
reinstate
third degree murder charges against the
four former minneapolis police officers
derek shovin was initially charged with
third degree murder and is now facing
two charges of second-degree
manslaughter
and second-degree murder according to a
report by the new york times
shogun had agreed to plead guilty to
third degree murder and a 10-year prison
sentence
but the report says then attorney
general william barr rejected the deal
because he was worried it would look too
lenient the times said the deal needed
federal approval
because chauvin asked to serve his time
in federal prison jury selection in
chauvin's trial is scheduled to start
on march 8. pornographer and
self-proclaimed first amendment champion
larry flint has died
angela levy takes a look back at his
life and legacy
larry flint was flamboyant and
controversial
his supporters call him a tireless
champion for the first amendment
but his critics always said that he was
just using the attention to make money
off of selling hardcore pornography well
we lost a giant
you know a lot of people just say oh
well he was a pornographer
he was so much more than that paul
cambria was larry flynn's longtime
lawyer and friend
flint's legal battles over images in
hustler magazine were legendary
he was arrested in the 70s in cincinnati
his conviction overturned on appeal
but flint's life changed forever in 1978
when serial killer joseph paul franklin
shot him outside of a courthouse in
georgia flint nearly died and was
paralyzed
from the waist down what franklin didn't
like there was a biracial couple
in in the magazines that went uh that uh
dark flynn put in there
it just drove him crazy so we said he
went the day before he knew where he was
where he was going to lunch every day
with his attorney so he found a building
right across the street
flint pressed on winning a case at the
u.s supreme court against the reverend
jerry falwell in 1988
the case determined that public figures
could not recover damages for satire
his supreme court case against jerry
falwell
was a landmark case it's cited
repeatedly by the supreme court as
president
back one last time to discuss the
passing of larry flint is terry austin
and imran i'm sorry
imran a controversial figure to many but
that put him in the limelight for the
first amendment issue
uh of freedom of speech thoughts on his
legacy and his passing
yeah brian listen that case which was uh
you know hustler versus falwell
um what is it's a landmark
groundbreaking first amendment case
i handle defamation cases brian and a
lot of times we're
we're citing to that case that really
stood up as a landmark case
for the first amendment supreme court
president and that really goes back to
larry flint
and his fight for his magazine and
standing uh firm
for his first amendment rights that
really stood that there's you know
parodies parity
a public figure is a public figure and
it really
provided some protections for free
speech in the press and that goes back
to larry flynn
yeah and terry there is no first
amendment case that i know of at least
where someone says something we all
agree on there's always some controversy
when it comes to first amendment cases
how do you think the world will remember
larry flint though
first amendment advocate hustler
magazine
target of advocacy what do you think i
think
all of the above there's no question
that many people think of him
as someone who published a you know
pornographic
magazine but i think his lawyer's right
he is much more than that he
is a business person first and foremost
and he did defend
his magazine and he wanted the right to
say
and do and publish what he thought was
something that the public
wanted and kudos for his success as far
as that's concerned
one thing i find very interesting is
that he really was against
trump and this whole first amendment
argument is interesting
thank you both for contributing and
thank you for joining us here on the law
on crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you